das kam jetzt überraschend gerade hatte
ich noch beim max-planck-institut für
radioastronomie in bonn nachgefragt wann
endlich das erste bild des schwarzen
lochs sagittarius a stern im zentrum
unserer galaxie der milchstraße
veröffentlicht wird frühestens im april
wird es soweit sein
da gibt es dann von ganz anderer seite
das erste bild es ist bei weitem nicht
so scharf von aussagekräftig aber es ist
ziemlich verblüffend und unerwartet ein
schwarzes loch wie kein anderes klicks
um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
es ist fast unmöglich ein bild des
schwarzen lochs im zentrum der
milchstraße zu machen zwischen der erde
und sarita rosa stern ist ein nebel aus
heißem gas er streut das licht und
erschwert die beobachtung oder bzw
macht sie nahezu unmöglich trotzdem ist
jetzt erstmals das nahezu unmögliche
gelungen und gelungen ist das wie beim
heiß erwarteten bild des event horizon
teleskops nur mit der zusammenschaltung
mehrerer radioteleskope in diesem fall
war es das very long baseline
interferometrie wie rb bei dem mehrere
teleskope auf der nordhalbkugel zum
beispiel das deutsche radioteleskop
effelsberg in der eifel mit dem atacama
large millimeter array kurz alba in
chile auf der südhalbkugel zusammen
geschaltet worden und so ein riesiges
virtuelles teleskop entstand das hat er
so fast die größe unserer erde und jetzt
kommt der hammer
nachdem das forschungsteam die streuung
herausgerechnet hatte stieß sie auf
einen leuchtend in einem extrem engen
bereich von nur einem 300 millionstel
eines winkel gab sarah ist vom
forschungsteam das deutet darauf hin
dass die radiostrahlung er von einer
scheibe mit einfallendem gasherd als von
einem radio z sie hat den gesammelten
daten mit zahlreichen computermodellen
durchgerechnet und kommt zu dem schluss
das würde allerdings sagen gitarrist
stern zu einer ausnahme gegenüber
in anderen schwarzen löchern machen von
denen wir radiostrahlung empfang eine
alternative wäre nur wenn der jet fast
direkt auf uns zeigt also ein ganz
besonderes schwarzes loch oder der schon
relativ unwahrscheinliche fall dass ein
jet aus dem schwarzen loch direkt auf
uns gerichtet ist keine falke professor
für astronomie hält diesen sehr
speziellen fall trotzdem für eine
möglichkeit das bedeutet dass wir das
biest unter einem besonderen blickwinkel
sehen allerdings wäre das schon sehr
seltsam das würde bedeuten dass die
akkretionsscheibe um das schwarze loch
im zentrum unserer galaxie exakt um 90
grad zur drehung ebene der galaxie
gekippt wäre das wäre ganz anders als
man sich das eigentlich vorstellen würde
demnach kreist um das schwarze loch eben
eine akkretionsscheibe in der drehung
ebene der galaxie und die jets gehen
senkrecht nach oben und unten aus der
drehung ebene der galaxie heraus eben
ganz anders als jetzt vermutet wird
jetzt wird es noch spannender was das
bild des event horizon teleskops zeigen
wird es macht das bild bei einer höheren
frequenz jetzt ist auf jeden fall sicher
dass wenn es einen schatten des
schwarzen loches gibt also wie ein blick
auf das loch erhaschen können er nicht
in der streuung verschwinden wird
sondern herausgerechnet werden kann noch
mehr über das erste bild im zentrum der
milchstraße gibt es hier unbedingt drauf
klicken bei raumzeit block der zukunft
abonnieren auch diesen kanal mit noch
ausführlicheren wissenschaft videos bis
dann bleibt dran